die kultur in wirklich nicht aber wir
passen sie zu sagen ja ich habe das
richtige benehmen vor sehr gut ist weg
verliert ist der kein stück ehingen ist
[Musik]
liebe fragen dich nach dem pass bibel
kann grenzenlos sein
wiegel nimmt uns an der hand und schon
sind wir hin und weg das sind schweizer
liebesgeschichten aus aller welt
[Musik]
amerika um endlich wieder unbegrenzt die
möglichkeit also kleine muss aber was
bedeutet amerika wenn es leider in der
schweiz plane kite und jetzt trägt sie
die dort zieht das paar tage mit der
familie vom thomas dummermuth unterwegs
[Musik]
thomas herzig vor zwölf jahren noch ein
üblicher hin und her und den am kopf ist
pfarrer aus maintal in der heimat vor
der chemiefabrik landet ältere wurde
jenny vormonat offenland wie zb mini
glaube zum fische und zum baubeginn für
thomas dem was ich genau bedeutet von
recaro user haben es fehle eine garage
parkieren
karas hierfür amerikanisch meisterlich
und die games und inkasso und
hitzeschutz ganz und gar nicht so ich
werde meine der typ nicht so viel steht
ihren ihren vater gerne sein
schwiegersohn wählers das alles gute
punkte das ist nämlich eine frage
wow sie meinen also dass fleisch
verarbeitet da wir das fleisch vom
metzger oder zaubern metzger natürlich
für die und nach red star des motivs und
sache und zaubert jagd sonst ja ja ja ja
das ist eine eigene welt ist das
geschehen schon sehr schmal
also ihre familie hobbys und das alles
so eine garage das ist ein detail vom
idealtypische leibnitz nebraska teil 2
ist ein eigenes stück land mit dem shop
ist baumwiese und wo man machen was man
will
so zeige die amerikanische variante vom
schweizer schrebergarten der handwerker
als schwiegersohn wie ist thomas o er
ist großartig
er schaut gut zu meinen enkeln ein guter
junge
ich liebe ihn enkelmann hat auch eine
angel für mich ich habe leider keine
ahnung vom fischen wirklich dann zeigen
wir dir war das für euch als jennifer
nach hause kam und sagte dass sie sich
in ein schweizer verliebt hat wir sind
glücklich dass sie ihn geheiratet hat
denn er ist ein toller mensch und er ist
wirklich ein super typ
[Musik]
the wonderbras kraft familie wurde jenny
ich extra sie
[Musik]
hast du schon eine fisch gefangen und
sich damit einen untertitel rund drei
stunden später
[Applaus]
das ist aber ein großer das ist dein vor
allem bausch und das ist das jetzt also
das sind zwei disziplinen aber jetzt
mache nach ständige bewegung gekommen
ist
heimat das monate sie traditionen
herkunft und heimat geben audi-manager
mit offenen armen aufnehme twitter
channel 4 und thomas kriner street sind
klein kriegen
die schweizer gesetze von dem hier sind
sehr ungerecht also wir sind verheiratet
müssen trotzdem jedes jahr immer noch
wieder einen antrag stellen für für ein
visa und weil sie aus einem drittstaaten
land kommt kostet das noch einmal mehr
als wenn jetzt dass ein europäisches
land wäre und es kürze gültig
[Musik]
langhans müsse warten jetzt ist also wie
vor gut vier jahren jeanette und petri
der schweiz zivilcourage jetzt rolex
quartal um pornos richtige hochzeit mit
allem drum und tragen
natürlich sind auch peter selter aus dem
wallis of singapore
martha und de france für sie ist der
neue welt mit der schwiegermutter im
schlepptau ganz gut albi garderobe
postens
[Musik]
aber ganz so einfach ist doch nicht am
peters internet hat am sport renault bis
rot leider und drum muss für mama eine
andere fahrbahn bieters machen
markus pätz kuala lumpur angeblicher
widerstand überwunden
bahn frei das große fest
es gibt hochzeitsvorbereitungen und
hochzeitsvorbereitungen
mit rosie kripo zara zellweger
elektronische fahrstufe gehört dass sie
der woche ihre bilanz belgrad vor ort
entscheiden die dokumente gefällt aber
hütte und oftmals sms klang jetzt doch
eigentlich gemeint dass man so will
eigentlich studie hatte unter der woche
jetzt sind die papiere doch eigentlich
als risikopartie kann einfach zum mini
ganzen unterlagen zusammen kann man das
mal als original das geburtenregister
die schweiz wir haben ja auch die
mentale über beglaubigt werden der
branche auch stille das ist ihr mann das
ist ein fakt naja ist das also heißt
dass das original aus dass das als
offizielles papier ist das muss der muss
spezielle über beglaubigung also die
gläubiger über beglaubigung habe und
weil ich dafür fühlte briefkasten
aufgemacht keine schreie gruppe habe ich
mich gefreut dass endlich ruhe ist ja
jetzt bin ich nur schnell gelöscht
damit verloren auf der b 12 stunden
autofahrt eines automechanikers ist auto
aus dem xmas ist auto will das
christkind stetig zum verfahren
die linke sieht weniger electronica
bereit was du zu machen ja doch
natürlich ziel wer die hose wo jetzt
vorab zu haben die hose und das op déi
rout ich jetzt nicht was immer mehr
traditionelle kleid um himmels willen
nein das ist nicht mein stil warum muss
es denn eigentlich so schnell letzte sie
mir einfach bei genügend distanz
hessische da ist wird er jetzt einfach
dass das funktioniert das erdreich oder
sein
ja ohne uni müsse darüber nachdenken wie
du hin dass ich das lied so dazwischen
das ist so er beleuchtet eigentlich und
ein ring mit hohen stückzahlen oder sony
klar bin ich das jetzt schon ziemlich
schräge also wie jede andere frau wenn
sie hier ortet praxis jahren fotos ich
weiß mit problem ist also eigentlich hat
wirklich nicht aus überzeugung muss kiel
hatte sich in einer woche zahlen sie
sondern will grenze vorgibt ein
zollgrenze vorgeht 45 nicht zusammen
aber ohne dass er kürzer sind und mir
einfach schöne zusammenarbeit
das ist einzig aber mir war
[Musik]
lerby frau geht nicht noch ein boss aber
migrationsbehörde show sarah lohnt sich
für ihre neue liebe cry grenze setzen
darum future music 200 km bis belgrad zu
sehen
[Musik]
wir werden versuchen von von unseren
beiden kulturen das beste mit
einzubringen und dann mal schauen was
herauskommt
also eines hoch das traditionelle
asiatische ritual und sv westrich
projekte oder seidige
begleiterscheinungen und dort zur tragik
von der brut andere länder andere
requisiten
die beste freundin eine fotoschau mit
sind bereit jetzt weil nur sie selber
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie stühle halbe stelle dass die ziele
nicht
gegenüber draußen dass die immer noch da
ich immer noch sich wie eine quelle war
war nicht siegt ist und ihr stil
darüber will sich ja so viel zeit ist
vergangen seit der konflikte und so
weiter aber still dann immer wieder gab
noch einmal stritt dass die wahl kein
unter villa und und die bedürfnisse
vieler nächstes machen die die wieder
die an rx machen dass das das immer noch
ich dass ich von mir hat bisher stünden
james
[Musik]
im winter im so moritz schweiz zieht die
pensionierung von bernard lambert im
haus ließ auf zwei kontinenten vorher
ins hin und her zyklus klar sind
schockiert von lie ist das eine gang
aber draußen und der berner sind zwei
menschen mozart hand nehmen wenn es
schwierigkeiten gibt
das gilt für sie privat aber auf ihr
engagement in der öffentlichkeit einmal
ermöglichen zieht wasserversorgung für
das dorf auf dem land ein anders mal
setzte sie sich dafür dass auch die
ärmsten zugang zu bekennen
das projekt eröffne
wohin beide besonders wichtig ist
erstmal baut und dann der regierung hat
normales schoss gegen also und ein handy
hans nimmer gemacht und nach sich ziehen
denn die für kinder gar tabelle und da
hat man das neue macher
frauen-liga am herz als paartherapeutin
probiert sie ihn als neues
selbstverständnis vermitteln und mit
ihrem stifter eventim hat jones vor der
frau in der gesellschaft verbessern
das neue schulhaus wird feierlich
eröffnet mahnende worte vorher schlief
verlor um sie geht es der frau zum
zeigen dass der schulbetrieb kann
funktionieren wenn man blickt
[Musik]
ich habe überhaupt nicht gewusst dass
ich für mich wir die ganzen ostblock das
ist irgendwie sowohl die schulen nicht
wirklich vernünftig behandelt wurde
nun kann ich mich wirklich dafür
interessiert
[Musik]
inzwischen zieht weiß sarah einiges mehr
belgrad und die schwierige zeiten wo die
serbische hauptstadt hinter sich hat
grundstücks herz torfmoore hat
[Musik]
und morgen die rote dort sarah ihren
milan
[Musik]
so jetzt dass alles gut ich mache mir
noch sorgen
wieso nur so ich hasse dieses ganze
schminken und so die chance ist voll zu
sein
manchmal ist es schwierig eine frau zu
dann trinken wir und zauberfußball
schön dich zu sehen
na endlich
sie würden es überleben das heißt
überleben
ihr werdet heiraten wie sieht die
hochzeit morgen aus zeigt was habt ihr
vor
ich werde ja sorgen die braut küssen und
dann können wir gehen vielleicht noch
ringe tauschen
ja natürlich
besitzer auf mich total cool wirkt aber
jetzt merken ihre tochter ashleigh der
spanier genauso sind maschinen noch aus
[Musik]
ich liebe auch die energie diese hat
dass er hat sehr viel
sie hat sehr viel power und bringt mir
sehr viel und sie ist eine ganz ganz
liebe und von der show
es ist morgen um die 5 aber weg den
jetlag und dem förderprogramm sind
ältere feierabend in der nacht vor der
hochzeit internet unter peter
traditionsgemäß nützen sie janet hat in
ihrem elternhaus übernachtet und peter
bereitet sich im hotel bis ihnen ältere
oft hoch zieht vor
gute show viel weiter jeanette wird die
traditionelle art geschminkt und recht
gemacht
ich bin endlich in der holz ich weiß
nicht alles
[Musik]
später wird schon betreut vor der
zeremonie am meisten
das ist brauch in blumenrod weiter als
priester sorge sie dafür das protokoll
vor ihrer hochzeit kalte wird und sie
weiter fürs publikum die mutter und
anschließend den vater
bitte janet die high court zu und her
wie er immobilien hus ihren vater
kümmert sich um die spirituellen
freundin erfurter brut sind für die
weltliche vorbereitungen zuständig der
täter muss nach mehreren fingern uhr
probe besteht für jeanette aus braubach
und
[Applaus]
dort tauchte bräutigams und los geht's
mit shoppen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
liebst du janet ja dann musst du das
hier auf essen stinkfrucht presse
schnaps trinken aber hinter der türe
wartet endlich die letzte hindernis
offen
hey hey jetzt sei
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn schritts protokolle teezeremonie
gut mit älteren bräutigam ihre tochter
über geld
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
im gegensatz zu haben
so gut zu meinem mädchen
[Musik]
es ist sehr anstrengend aber auch sehr
lustig ich bin sehr glücklich dass wir
diese traditionelle hochzeit feiern
können
ich freue mich jetzt darauf auf deinen
eltern zu servieren
ältere von peter wartet unterdessen im
hotel & ride wird das kommando
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
er stets lauter und der frauen steht ron
grant ist malaysische hochsitz prozedere
erfüllt
von jeannette und peter offiziell
besiegelt
[Musik]
ich hatte schwierige zeiten
meine langjährige beziehung zerbrach
meine tochter zog in die usa ich musste
mein leben von grund auf ändern
ich brauchte einen neustart aber jetzt
bin ich wieder in der spur
es gibt liegt wo seht dass er hoch zb
weiter besonders viel glück bringt wenn
das stimmt uns für zara und der milan
ganz gut mit gott belgrad mi amor
freiwillige flüge
[Musik]
wenig tüte trophy da sieht man zuletzt
ein grad die binationale ehe zwischen
dem milan petrovic und dass sarah
zellweger klasse wird
statt den himmel vorlage geht es einmal
kapelle wofür es nötig probiert ein
ganzer entfällt der raum ins geld
es ist nur handflächen dort die mutter
von milan 3 züge und zwei kollegen
[Musik]
das ist dieselbe standesbeamtin und zum
glück für zara ein übersetzer eb
guten tag willkommen bei konzertgemeinde
[Musik]
frauen mit dem gast
stimmen sie dieser eheschließung mit
mehreren in italienisch zu
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn's glück will in seiner wohnung vor
kurzem oder mac-rechner tätig zum
beispiel am regnerischen tag auf dem
standesamt in belgrad
sarah willkommen in der familie passt
gut darf ihn auch er ist immer noch ein
baby dies hat mich überrascht
altmodisch etablieren dass muss jetzt
aber andere
[Musik]
bitte sarah und dem elan spürbar die
große freude und erleichterung dass sie
endlich offiziell dafür sein leben für
sie braucht drei rutschen die hochzeits
party mit 100 gäste am schluss gemeinsam
mit patience einfach geduld lenkung zu
gut
[Musik]
wird sarah und dem milan hat sich worte
punkt
[Musik]
nun diese kilometer wie der im osten
erwartet jeanette und peter für ihre
traumhochzeit rund 400 gäste sogar
führen erfahrene heute lebender vater
franz alle dimensionen sprengt
das ist also haben wir noch viel die
eigene mitte finden ist studiert aber
wenn die fähig studiert hatte also es
ist unvorstellbar was sich das volk er
ist denkt also wirtschaftlich hochzieht
einzigartige kenntnis
jetzt ist er voll da und da ich weiß was
ich dachte sie mir die schweizer sitz
wenig
[Musik]
die mit dem klo bist du
nein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
du bist wirklich die beste und auch die
schönste frau jeanette du bist mein wahr
gewordene traum
[Applaus]
zum ersten mal und tanzte mit ihrer der
hochzeitstanz für peter und jeanette ist
alles aufgegangen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich war eine achterbahn der gefühle
ich war gestresst glücklich dann wieder
paranoid und wieder glücklich
ich war überrascht und manchmal
geschockt dann wieder glücklich noch nie
hatte ich so viele emotionen an einem
einzigen tag
es war unglaublich
[Musik]
sie ging sofort ruft fahrer wo sie wie
in der deutschkurs besucht
mehr als 120 gefunden über alle grenzen
hinweg die grenze in tranchen an die
bayern hatten ihr aus internet sorgt
höchstens als muse von dreck und darum
machen sie auch genauso offen für alles
im alter wird in den senegal zum lage
ist es für die beiden deinen option zum
für immer miteinander absolut zusammen
weise nicht wieso verlags vorgestellt
also für winter für mich grund mit dem
frack und wer vorbei gemacht damit der
erste schritt weiter so
die hand york seit und worte und das
york spürt eine beide hütten jedem
moment
für mich ist meine ganz glücklich dass
ich ihn gefunden haben und ich finde
keine andere münchen
so zeige
[Musik]
so behauptet
[Gelächter]
wirklich so mit katy perry und rosenheim
mehr machen das irgendwie meine damen
romantik behalten dass die kpd finden